throws us apart from lions as humans is
that we have fought
yeah but you can't undo our you can't
undo our biology is the thing and i
think
it's not
women can have the choice right they can
have the choice to do whatever they want
i support that but a lot of times we lie
to women and say they're going to be
happy when the least happy group of
women is 45 single and childless i think
we're lying i think we lied to people in
terms of what happiness even really is
and what it should feel i feel that you
know in society we're told that
happiness is this continuous state of
euphoria to some people we don't really
argue the fact that we're all trying to
achieve this certain state and
life but actually that state of life is
just completely misrepresented and
unrealistic yeah i think the word we
should be using is self-happiness so i
remember when the other girls were here
they're looking i need to be happy i
think the word that you need to say is
fulfillment or joy
because happiness i can take an extra
pill and be happy
yeah definitely fulfillment joy um and i
think purpose as well and i think where
we ask this question about well should
we even
should we even
like why is even life even existed well
it's i think what well
in the comment you made earlier about
life what about being anti-life yeah
being anti-life but in a way it's like
okay well
you know we're
with all this purpose we want to have
that we all are seeking meaning within
what is we're trying to do yeah but what
could be more meaningful than a child
than life yeah i i think like the most
basic
the most basic like tenant of survival
is life must continue yeah like
everybody knows that if we don't let
life continue then we have no survival
because even even me like i have a
career let's say i hit a million subs or
10 million subs let's say this gets
really huge it means nothing if i don't
have a kid 65 like you're gonna be 65
and alone and happy at christmas but
what's the message you're trying to put
out there to people
what do you mean so like you're saying
you could have a million subs and then
even then if you then if you don't have
a child then then it kind of means
nothing but then without that child
there
but you're still doing something so
without the child though yeah without
even having a child by you creating a
platform with a million subscribers for
example and actually putting these
conversations out well my message is
that feminism lies to women and they
tell you to prioritize your career above
all else when families what's the most
important thing and if women are free to
choose what they want to choose do what
you want to do
but
it's dishonest to say you're going to be
happy if you chase the bag the thing is
women actually know this and they deny
it to themselves do you know i mean like
women know that they are the most
fulfilled
when they are pursuing that
life of a husband or even it's not a
husband if it's a partner and a child
and that family life and i think women
have now been
convinced oh no you know what that's not
what it is chase the bag and it's like
well the people that are chasing the bag
are the most unhappy you know what i i
agree and i disagree because
as tiffany said and someone else said it
as well like you can be happy and
fulfilled with your career and things
like that and some people are just
naturally nurturing and maternal and
some people actually aren't
when you're naturally maternal and
nurturing you want that you crave that
but there's some women out there who
actually aren't yeah even if they are
sorry to call you but even if they have
a child then it's like what do they say
some every child deserves a parent but
not every parent deserves a child so um
i think
yeah that's where my mind says i think
sometimes what feminine sometimes says
you can have it all but they say the lie
is you can have it all at the same time
i think what the doctrine should be you
can have it all but different times so
for example when you're young i think a
woman's priority is to raise her family
once the children are old then pursue
the career so you have the best of both
worlds but i think
when it comes to like the whole baby
daddy and baby mother situation is that
women have
children and then
after having the children they want to
try and do the whole hot girl summer
thing you know i mean it's like let's do
it after i've had children it's like
well you know
sometimes you kind of chose your blame
that's like sometimes how weird is it
when i see girls like they'll come on
the show they'll have kids and i look at
their instagram it's like their ass is
all over instagram i'm like i will be
mortified if i was a kid and my mom ever
put something like that on the internet
like and i and i think about this and i
don't have kids like when i post [ __ ]
i'm like i want to have kids someday i
can't have anything like weird that i
don't want them to see i guess it's kind
of telling of the society that we live
in as well because you know a lot of
women the majority of women they're
looking at this standard of like you
know the superstars the you know i don't
want to put names out there but you know
who i'm talking about all those people
out there they've had their children and
they're still out here on
the swimsuits etc etc etc i'm not here
to judge anyone i know where my standard
of life is it comes from the most it
comes from scripture that's my standard
jonathan and i think that standard is
conducive to life it's like we said
earlier anti-life and i think because
women see that
they just they want that they and
they're not thinking okay what's best
for me what
i don't know i kind of haven't unlocked
that but i think that's what the
standard in society is that's what
society is selling women nowadays and
they're falling into that do any women
here today have kids currently on the
panel
i don't okay since i've missed the
mothers can i just say something i know
it's the hottest day of the year but i'm
hot because i've had so much stuff this
evening that i disagree with i'm so hot
but it seems i'm not gonna get the the
direct
retort that i was hoping that you were
hoping so i just want to make it clear
right now yeah yeah don't worry don't
get better
because this is you don't get better
than your baby father nine times out of
ten right yeah you don't yeah and
negative personal experience from the
general rule does not prove anything
yeah to earn i know this doesn't refer
to you two but i just need to get this
off my chest because i feel like some
viewers are like there's no one gonna
address this like
to earn to my humble opinion
to earn twice as much as the average
male yeah
is extremely extraordinary here and if
you're some and for somebody to be in
such an extraordinary circumstance yeah
yeah they have to have a level of
respect for that and not make it sound
like it's just average joel stuff
because in their day you the fact that
you're in such an extraordinary personal
circumstance doesn't disprove the rule
it doesn't disprove the argument really
it doesn't okay good question just to
fraud
to the sisters here
do you think that um because
it's very easy to say why can't you be a
wife one of the things that kevin
samuels was always saying who taught you
to be a wife but then again we don't
have families or institutions that can
teach young women to be a wife you see
so
is it i think it's a bit harsh to expect
that to happen in the 21st century
because let's face it especially what
gets pumped up in the media or in what
we watch that will influence you wasn't
that sorry traditionally from the mother
or the grandmother to palestine yeah but
we don't have that these days we have
broken families now so in that sense not
all families are broken right so there
has to be somewhere in the family where
that can happen i think in the western
cult uh context as like i said the
poorest demographic is obviously uh the
black community you don't want to say
that what's the hesitation for so
long to say it's a lot like you like you
was weighing it up like who might it be
roll it off the tongue
okay
but i'm just saying though that um like
from when we had the um
three ladies here and obviously they
were saying that they're single moms and
stuff like that
the argument is okay
did what example did they see about a
consecutive like nuclear family and
stuff like that and it's hard not a
feminine one well i said the baby mama
culture has has taken over whether it be
in the house whether it be in the media
and the thing is there's no shame
anymore that's not that's the other
thing like
every bad decision a girl makes she's
bailed out of thank you every every
single one and it's really frustrating
because if if a girl gets pregnant right
she can get bailed out by an abortion or
she can become a single mom and then get
money from the government or